[Musique]
m finale à
à
[Musique]
et vous êtes vacciné galant oui obligé
mais vous n'auriez pas fait si vous
n'avez pas été obligée non non parce que
je pense que ça fonctionne pas et que
c'est plus générateur de
chose qu'on va baisser nos problèmes
cardiaques et autres qu'on sait pas
encore mais l'ajout weick une cigarette
à la main en termes d'avc prime
cardiaque c'est pierce a annoncé par m
pour tout fait
[Applaudissements]
on est sur le pas de tir de cap
canaveral ne m'appartient la fusée et
vous rendez compte de tout ça et quand
il a dû s'avouer vraiment extraordinaire
regardez moi cette belle chimie de
manuels mercredi elle va décoller en
beta très loin pour la voir partir
tout est possible